this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond register for free at
dndbeyond.com to start your adventure
the holidays are over and we're hard at
work on a ton of big honest trailers and
awesome new stuff for the year ahead
just not this week here's a bunch of dc
episodes strung together while we get a
running start for 2022
[Music]
from zack snyder the visionary director
behind legend of the guardians the owls
of gahool comes the world's most hopeful
superhero in his inevitable dark moody
christopher nolan update because god
forbid a superman movie be any damn fun
for anybody
man of steel
prepare for a mopey violent reboot
guaranteed to depress adults and
frighten small children where one of
america's greatest icons superman is
played by this english man with the
acting range of a crumpet who are you
i am your father cow
that's my name but my god what a
beefcake he's the hero who stood for
truth justice and the american way but
this time stands for destroying american
property that's a 12 million dollar
piece of hardware it was the canadian
arctic
this guy's livelihood
bruce wayne satellite downtown
smallville
and like half of metropolis
it's a bird it's a plane it's coming
right for us everybody run
journey to superman's birthplace of
pandora or krypton an alien planet full
of avatar birds matrix babies sepia tone
way too many subplots krypton's core is
collapsing this council has been
disbanded i know you stole the codex i
will fight him and ships shaped like
wangs
meet general zod a kryptonian out to
destroy humanity with the power of
dubstep
[Music]
in order to defeat zod superman must
decide which of his two robin hood dads
to listen to
space dad says show off your powers to
inspire humanity you could be the bridge
between two peoples farm dad says hide
your powers and let innocent people die
what was i supposed to do just let them
die maybe watch superman honor them both
as he shows off his powers and lets
innocent people die
meet lois lane a pulitzer prize winning
reporter i'm a pulitzer prize-winning
reporter that's what i just said she's a
superhero in her own right with the
powers of staying alive in subfreezing
temperatures scaling ice mountains
seducing hot space dudes and showing up
wherever the plot needs her to be
general zod would like this woman to
accompany me come on there's no reason
she should be on the military plane it's
supposed to go in all the way
that's what she said
when lois uses her nikon camera to
photograph this budweiser creaking alien
she'll discover the truth from his
friend at the ihop but when zod sends
her a message on this nokia phone it's
up to superman to take him on with this
u-haul truck through this 7-eleven back
to the ihop and inside this sears
so if you loved the christopher rivera
superman movies but wish they made them
less hopeful killed countless civilians
visualized our worst fears of urban
terrorism and had superman overcome his
first villain by murdering him with his
bare hands dc has made the reboot for
you psycho
[Applause]
yikes starring specific zod april o'neil
ghost ad fallout box art kevin costco
perry black superman pooping and those
pin art desktop things you know from
spencer's gifts the one you used to
press your face against you guys know
what i'm talking about right man of
steel
can't believe i'm now actually rooting
for ben affleck to kick this guy's ass
[Music]
from zack snyder and his accurately
named production company comes the
blockbuster that united the world's two
biggest superheroes and divided everyone
else
batman v superman
dawn of justice
get ready for the battle of the century
between critics and fans that had the
movie's most rabid supporters sending
out death rats while its harshest
critics refused to admit that anything
about it was cool even though you'd be
lying if you thought this wasn't awesome
and this wasn't ridiculous
martha
why did you say that
warner brothers needed a surefire mega
hit to keep pace with the mcu now
they're pairing a screenwriter who once
said batman vs superman is where you go
when you admit to yourself you've
exhausted all possibilities and a
director who once said batman could get
raped in prison that could happen in my
movie
really strange choices in retrospect
you were promised the dawn of the
justice league and they delivered an
email attachment as the dc extended
universe kicks off with a folder of low
res quicktime videos who designed the
logos leaving audiences with a cool new
batman movie trapped inside a boring
convoluted superman sequel trapped
inside whatever cartoon lex luthor is
from
hmm
ahoy and i
no am
no what am i i suppose i say
the man of steel you know and fear has
returned
and even he's not sold on the whole
superman gig superman was never real
witness the hero who once do stood for
truth justice in the american way stand
for brooding moping and wondering why he
even bothers as the film's main
character has nothing to do but silently
look constipated get horrible pep talks
from his parents be anything they
and refused to fight back against his
toughest opponent yet cable news
superman was involved in the planning of
this attack he is not a hero must there
be
a superman stop scaling and [ __ ]
interview smile go to carpool karaoke
and sing that five for fighting song
i'm more than a bird i'm more than a
plane but my god
he's still a beefcake those abs are so
good you won't even notice how fake
those eggs are
watch zack snyder prove once and for all
that the hero he really wanted to make
movies about is this guy or at least his
weird murdery fanfic version
ben affleck shines as batman who's one
part crossfit bro one part superman one
part tony stark one part arkham video
game and one part actual bat
the thrill while the world's greatest
detective finally gets to do some actual
detective work as the actor we all
assumed would be the worst part of this
movie is by far the best part of this
movie tell me
do you plead also everything wonder
woman did was really cool sorry that
seems kind of tacked on and out of place
but you know so was she
she with you i thought she was with you
of course she's with you you sent her an
email like half an hour ago remember
watch the dark knight grow to hate
superman for clear obvious reasons while
superman grows to hate batman back
because lex luthor hired someone to kill
a criminal batman brandon before he put
him in prison so that when clark kent
refused to cover the local football team
and investigated the gotham vigilante
instead he would conclude that
look i don't have time to explain the
whole thing can we just roll x's plan
real quick okay let's see here um okay
right all right the cia yeah let's see
okay i don't even remember that part oh
yeah there it is okay uh step nine a
yeah okay i forgot about that part
p in a jar
man this is complicated you don't have
to throw everything but the kitchen sink
into your evil plan
[Music]
and there's the sink
you've been waiting since you were a kid
to see these two icons go toe to toe
well keep waiting for two working hours
through boring congressional hearings
let me say at the outset that i'm
grateful to our witness so
much journalism why aren't we covering
this and a semester's worth of intro to
philosophy lectures god is all-powerful
he cannot be ugly to finally get the
awesome fight you were promised in the
title that ends after just eight minutes
because their moms have the same name
i know batman's hung up on his dead
parents but come on he has the power to
wipe out the entire human race and if we
believe there's even a one percent
chance that he is our enemy we have to
take it as an absolute certainty having
a mom changes none of that motivation no
matter what her name is you can write
all the essays you want convincing
yourself this was brilliant then again
dumb is a one-syllable word that covers
it pretty well
so suit up for a film that was so highly
anticipated it could never have lived up
to the height that had to deliver the
fight fans have wanted to see on the big
screen for decades address the
controversy around man of steel make
enough money to compete with marvel be a
sequel to man of steel and a batman solo
movie pander to of pea enthusiasts form
the justice league introduce wonder
woman the flash aquaman cyborg lex
luthor pair of demons doomsday
steppenwolf the death of superman whose
idea was it to cram all this into one
movie they just burned through like six
movies worth of good material
ugh
but at least suicide squad looks pretty
cool though right
starring batfleck forever last son of
crapped on lady in the water jeremy's
iron hector salamanca teenage mutant
abomination lord of the rings cave troll
max landis worst product placement ever
what the hell is even happening here had
to ask like 10 hardcore dz fans and even
some of them didn't know
xena warrior cameo a democratic senator
from kentucky
sure why not tonight a comedian died in
gotham
martha wayne
and martha kent oh now i get it
nope still dumb fans v batman v superman
the critics be other fans the executives
v zack snyder the expectations can't do
them all justice
how come dad never left kansas you let
him die in a tornado remember
[Music]
from the studio that owns awesome heroes
like batman and superman comes a film
about the worst heroes ever and that's
from their actual trailer way to go guys
you want us trailered yourself suicide
squad
after the mixed reception to their last
movie warner brothers probably regret
spending just six weeks on the script
for this one now they have four short
months to reshuffle their executives
juggle seven different cuts reshoot the
third act deliver on all the joker stuff
they already put in the trailers and
manage a director who takes shots at
their biggest competition
it's like there's some kind of
what's the word what we some kind of
suicide squad man this thing is writing
itself
with superman level threats on the rise
amanda waller has a solution she's
bringing together a bunch of bad guys to
save the world this girl can do some
pretty incredible things from the bad
guys she brought together to save the
world do your worst [ __ ] they're high
on attitude but dangerously low on
relevant skills like a man who's half
crocodile half racial stereotype any
other requests
a guy who shoots fire but won't i'm
gonna die in peace before i raise my
fists again one chicken chomping
exposition machine who blurts out
whatever the pod needs him to we gotta
cut her heart out here comes slipknot
the man who can climb anything her
heart's out we can end this a drunk guy
with a boomerang some steven seagal
looking ass rope dork a 90 pound girl
with a bat
sorry a lady just kind of shows up and
barely says anything and has a magic
sword isn't even a bad guy why is she
here this is katana she's got my back i
would advise not getting killed by her
her sword traps the souls of its victims
that's good to know and will smith doing
everything he can to save this movie if
she can't cut it and her grades start
slipping i need you white people that
thing uh-huh you know how y'all do oh
yeah in a world of flying men and
monsters this is the only way to protect
our country is it though
you'll love these good guys gone bad but
they're going up against bad guys who
are even better than the bad good guys
with bad bad guys like the putties from
power rangers with caviar all over their
faces olmec from legends of the hidden
temple and the enchantress an ancient
spirit released by the world's worst
archaeologist
watch carol de la v make the jump from
modeling to acting like the wavy
inflatable arm things outside car
dealerships ashy formulates an evil plot
to destroy the world with wait let me
guess it's a sky beam isn't it
surrounded by rubble and a disposable
cgi army too right man this really
sounds like a job for the avengers or
really any other movie in the last 10
years
but we know fans are only here for one
reason the joker and they're barely
gonna get any of him experience jared
leto's intense method acting that
blurred the line between actor character
and total douchebag how did you send
used condoms to oh everybody as he does
in just 10 minutes of screen time what
no other actor has been able to do
make the joker totally suck in an
interpretation that combines james
franklin spring breakers look at mine
with ace ventura this handsome honka
hunker
alrighty then and the cat i think
[Applause]
it's so edgy you could cut him out of
the movie and it wouldn't make any
difference
get ready for a film that loves
exposition almost as much as it hates
helicopters
as they literally spell out who the
characters are tell you how they're
feeling at all times she seems nice that
is just a mean
lady
you are evil and keep reminding you
who's good and who's bad the worst are
the worst these are villains amanda you
notice these are criminals we're bad
guys and i'm the bad guy don't forget
we're the bad guys we get it you all
suck
so gear up with the film we all thought
would put the dc extended universe back
on track but instead gave us two hours
of characters trying to look cool to a
soundtrack that feels like someone
scanning through a radio dial
[Music]
with great performances by will smith
margot robbie and jack courtney of all
people that get canceled out by this
hula hooping witch and this manorexic
juggalo but hey at least wonder woman
looks pretty good right
story
one-eyed willie violent davis daddy's
little cosplayer heath lesser that's not
a knife dia de los mettos to crocodile
just the worst gi blows real american
zero
this is katana she's got my back i would
advise not getting killed by her her
sword traps the souls of its victims
lawnmower man
am i too soon i'm too soon
and what it felt like watching this
movie
the boondoctanes
that was our main satellite plate oh no
now all they have left is the satellite
they used to film the other satellite
[Music]
from the studio known for confusing
length with depth complexity with
intelligence and self-absorbed downers
with heroism the dc eu pulls off its
biggest success yet by
not doing those things
wonder woman
[Music]
after supergirl catwoman and elektra
studios doubted a female-led superhero
movie could succeed now patty jenkins
bravely asks the question what if a
female-led superhero movie wasn't
absolute garbage from beginning to end
and had a powerful message for girls
save the world look flawless doing it be
a literal god then men might
begrudgingly half tolerate your presence
so if this woman can read it we should
hear what she has to say
yes very well
progress
settle in for an origin story about the
greek gods inside an origin story for
wonder woman inside an origin story for
world war ii the armistice is of
paramount importance and visit this cryo
the miscrea the themisia
visit xena warrior island a society of
women trained from birth to cover for
gal gadot's accent in the events of an
invasion this belonged to the greatest
warrior in our history you need to tell
us now yes but aerys is behind that
corruption these amazons have been
preparing their whole lives to fight the
god of war ares and you can bet that
when war reaches their shores they'll
get wrecked by german teams with bolt
action rifles
[Music]
maybe send out a scout once every 500
years or at least deploy some of your
invisible jets i know you have them
meet diana a girl never actually
referred to as wonder woman she's the
hero the dceu doesn't deserve but sure
as hell needs right now she's optimistic
confident iron-willed vulnerable
uncompromising and just
so hot i can say that right i mean i
don't want to come off like james
cameron because it's definitely not the
only thing she's got going for but damn
she's stronger faster and smarter than
the men around her but every superhero
has a kryptonite and hers is not knowing
jack about anything war
what war it's a watch tells time what
for why are they holding hands what do
these women wear into battle does the
average man not sleep what is a
secretary at the front
front of what
marriage
you speak a hundred languages you know
what marriage means
experience this groundbreaking superhero
movie but not so groundbreaking that
they didn't put one of the bankable
hollywood chris's in it chris pine
surprises and delights in a performance
that gives him his first lead in the
great hollywood chris off but he's more
than just eye candy he's diana's
emotional support a voice of caution and
a love interest in constant need of
rescue
hey they gave him the role women always
have to play against the male
superheroes didn't they i see what you
did there
in a film with two grounded complex
leads cringe and villains pulled from a
different much campier movie but the
musk won't help they don't know that
that seems to forget the germans in
world war one were not the nazis one of
the good guys
and those are the bad guys seriously
expects us to buy this human milk
thistle as the god of war and implies
that wonder woman kept her head down for
all of hitler and stalin
but did suit up the moment lex luthor
made a ninja turtle
you know what i'm sorry for even
bringing bvs into this let's just let
this one stand on its own
so get ready for a film about balancing
the good and bad in all of us that
contains good and bad within itself in
this flawed but important movie that's
no less important for having flaws is it
an inspirational well-made film that
finally gives women a superhero to be
proud of yes does it end with a
lightning hands mustache man yelling
video game level dialogue and i believe
in love then
i will destroy you
also yes
starring
amazon prime
want to touch the piney
also the queen and gladiator princess
cutter up oh party boy
would you
apologize a drunk scotsman
a sneaky frenchman a wise old indian
guide what are these guys the howland
stereotypes pam beasley i mean don
tinsley
and snyder vision
a justice league of her own
maybe you're better off without me yeah
no charlie who will sing for us um your
friend clearly has ptsd
let him go home
[Music]
somewhere between the awful suicide
squad and the excellent wonder woman a
new dc movie will get it sorted down the
middle but when the best comic book
characters ever unite for a film that's
just okay
you blew it again ah how does this keep
happening
justice league
in the midst of a production beset by
tragedy warner brothers bravely forged
ahead so executives could keep their
bonuses mixing zack snyder's trademark
gloom with the optimism of joss whedon
and the priorities of brett radner's
production company
you're gorgeous that results in its own
signature blend of orange lots and lots
of orange man i wish they released the
snyder cut also man i wish the snyder
cut wasn't a made-up fanboy pipe dream
witness a film that looks like it's
being rendered right before your eyes
where this cgi villain steals the cgi
boxes from their cgi hiding places
uniting the cgi heroes in a big cgi
fight on a cgi battlefield until the cgi
hero merges with the cgi box while the
cgi villain gets punched in the mouth by
the hero with a mouth made out of cgi
yes ma'am ugh that just looks wrong
meet the justice league a bunch of sad
losers i want to be left alone if you
stay up here brooding i'm processing
well i wouldn't count on the tribes of
men i need friends who occasionally make
jokes now dostoevsky there's wonder
woman the three-dimensional hero turned
into girl hung up on her ex i lost
someone i loved i once knew a man would
have loved to fly it when it's your
fault they're all steve trevor broseidan
king of the broshen amen cyborg who's
there booyah
spiderman who in this movie goes by the
flash superman and god mouth is so
distracting poor henry cavill worked out
for months for this role but all i can
look at is weird fake baby mouth they
really couldn't just shave his mustache
or grow a beard or you know delay the
movie
and of course the batman he may not be
that tough
or that smart so your genius move is
dying or that careful with his secret
identity dressed like a bat you're out
of your mind bruce wayne first way he's
a batman that's a bad signal that's your
oh
sorry that's your signal
but
wait there's no butt that's a shame he
was the best part of the last one
prepare for the arrival of steppenwolf
dc's scariest horn helmeted minor god
villain with a giant bladed weapon since
the movie right before this one he's got
a generic look a generic motivation he
lived only to conquer and super generic
dialogue find the last one its power
will cleanse this world you're all too
weak to see the truth i am
the ends of wars but no character since
buster bluth has ever been this much of
a mother lover mother i know mother
prays to the mother i see
mother
what the hell is that these are my words
from army how is it possible they ripped
off everything from the avengers except
the good villain come on joss it's not
stealing if you do it from yourself
after all the intricate plotting of
batman v superman check out a sequel
that says whoops never mind pretending
batman knew clark kent for more than 15
minutes and the team needs clark
pretending the world didn't hate
superman before he died so much
bitterness of course i think it's all
because he's gone and pretending that
bizarre flash nightmare sequence never
happened
i mean that was clearly meant for when
this movie was going to be a two-parter
right
so where the avengers felt like the end
of the beginning for the mcu experienced
dc's big team-up movie that just kind of
feels like the end where they emptied
out their easter egg cupboard united all
their biggest superheroes and tried
everything they could to make it look
like they still cared you know you can't
do this forever i can barely do it now
it's a shame too they were just starting
to take some real steps toward heroism
save one
save one person okay baby steps
starring
a wad of tinfoil scrunched around a
laser pointer
jason moana the dark night owl
the dceu hunger games champion
super side eye
the voice of warner brothers we might
not have thought this through death pool
i mean dead stroke
smashed mouth
spider car spider car does whatever a
spider car does
oh myles dyson when will you learn
mike pence
speeder parker
and a recast luther
care for a glass of goude diamond oh
and not starring trailer shots and
scenes that weren't in the final movie
aquaman consumed by water cyborg as a
human and letterman jacket the i didn't
think you were real scene didn't think
you were real i'm real and it's useful
cyborg fighting a tank and talking to a
cop you should probably move flash
fighting a pair demon cyborg is a human
playing football the original blue color
palette in sequence bruce looking at
holographic superman barry breaking
glass alfred talking to a mysterious
visitor he said you've come and lois and
clark discussing their engagement i'll
take that as a yes
what
warner brothers presents joss whedon
zack snyder's justice league part one of
one
so uh why does everyone in this movie
have super smelling fear i can smell it
the demons must have caught the scent of
a mother box who scent is on you you
could smell a story you recognize that
smell you smell good
did i not before
[Music]
they've depressed you
they've inspired you
and they've let owed you hong kong
now warner brothers in dc are back to
just completely overwhelm you
what is happening
aquaman
remember aquaman the nerd that talks to
fish my ability to talk with fish is of
no help wonder woman well he's gone from
zero to hunky hero watch as the pure
charisma of jason momoa supercharges the
character transforming him into a sexy
undersea superman who's super fast super
strong a lot of the time
and mostly invulnerable
okay so his powers are kind of
inconsistent but so what everyone knows
that this aquaman's real power is this
motor
mission to come aboard permission
granted sailor uh i mean is it hot in
here
strap in as arthur curry embarks on a
reluctant quest to become king arthur
but you know like the cool version i
give you
king arthur and he's not alone here to
help our princess mira and his mother
queen atlanta two powerful women
struggling to overcome terrible wigs
together they'll hunt for a mythical
trident that will mark him as the one
true king by giving him his comic book
accurate
costume holy crap he actually makes that
dumb orange and green suit look cool
hail to the king baby did you think
there was a lot going on in avengers
infinity war
we'll hold this man's beer because
thanos may have brought you chaos in the
cosmos but aquaman is a whirlwind of so
many locations the movie added titles to
keep track from amnesty bay to the
boston aquarium over the sahara on route
to italy to somewhere in the atlantic
ocean to somewhere in the indian ocean
from atlantis to the hidden sea whatever
the kingdom of the brine is and a bunch
of other underwater places all while
living through massive undersea battles
featuring nights on seahorses fighting
mermaids and crab men in between scenes
of overly complicated game of thrones
politics we honor you king narius by
inviting zebel to be the first kingdom
to join king orms alliance as if you had
a choice vocal by law you need four of
the seven kingdoms to send an attack
once you've obtained the pledge of the
while still making time for indiana
jones adventures a little mermaid love
story a blood view with high-tech
pirates and that's before taking a quick
lap in the dinosaur field court of the
earth summoning a guide you and bringing
peace to the world
wait what happened i think i blacked out
so get ready to jump the shark all of
the sharks and then shoot at those
sharks with water powered plasma cannons
in a movie so packed to the gills it
couldn't just tell one aquaman story it
had to tell all of them at once forcing
director james wan to start pumping out
aqua adjacent spin-offs to buy some time
to figure out how in the heck he's going
to top this bonkers thing and if i might
make a suggestion maybe a prequel about
how this octopus learned to play the
drums
not quite my tempo
downbeat on 18.
you're rushing
here we go
starring
jack cousteau
merlady
maureen goblin
eric fishmonger
atlanta
jenga wet if he drowns he throws
war machine
crap people cry people seamen come on we
had to
kai julie andrews
patrick wilson yelling
[Applause]
[Music]
and explosive interruptions legend has
it that one day a new king will come
his loyalty is to this
the clue to atlan's final resting place
oh come on how often do explosions
really
the water boy
okay look i know people think this is
similar to another comic book movie
where two ideologically opposed family
members clash over the kingship of a
hidden high-tech civilization but hear
me out this one is underwater
[Music]
from the studio that's gone from doom
and gloom to fins and grins comes a fun
field ride for the kid inside everyone
just maybe not actual kids
kill the little girl
shazam
meet billy batson he's got the street
smarts of bart simpson and the street
wear of tyrone bigums
when billy gets lured into a cave by an
old man who claims to be a wizard which
to be clear kids is never a good idea
lay your hands on the staff he'll become
one of dc's classic characters captain
marvel no he used to be captain marvel
but dc changed it to shazam that's kazam
common mistake i mean the guy obsessed
with being worthy and lightning no the
street round who gets wish fulfillment
powers wish fulfillment three wishes to
be exact
okay it's the one where chuck flosses
gather round for a heartwarming tale
that out families fast and the furious
i'm a big believer in finding family you
know me time could also be construed as
pushing away his family if a superhero
can't save his family he's not much of a
hero thank you for this family you don't
turn your back on family we're in a
change of pace for marvel's constant
daddy issues we get another installment
of dc's sad mom parade forgive me for
everything if you choose to leave you
may never return i'm sorry i never told
you i felt ashamed um it's me
um
that was not a really good time for me
as billy learns that family isn't about
who abandoned you at a carnival on a
whim it's about the people you're forced
to live with who love you because you're
constantly saving their asses from being
killed
come on come on come on come on but
shazam will have to fight more than just
the overburdened foster care system he's
up against dr savannah a veteran
character actor out for revenge on dc
for casting him as sinestro in green
lantern watch him unleash the power of
the seven deadly sins each its own
representation of a different human
failing with unique powers that actually
no never mind they're all just kind of
grey blobs who just eat people man the
rock cannot get here fast enough does
the next one really have to be about the
very angry caterpillar the seven realms
are about to be hours
[Laughter]
follow-up question what
so cheer along sdc finally cracks the
code on making a heartwarming fun
inspiring movie about an invincible
strong man a superman if you will that
gives kids everything they dream of no
not turning into a 38 year old in a
styrofoam muscle suit no not terrorizing
the boys who make your life a living
hell i'm talking about a kid's ultimate
power fantasy developing a moderate
youtube following doing it for the memes
baby smash that like button
shazam
story
you're a wizard billy
the movie trying to write the starring
section for us thunder crack captain
sparkle fingers power voice maximum
voltage is it mr philadelphia human
power storm frequency flinger slurs apps
a lot yeah not so easy is it good chief
of staff see now that's how it's done he
is a villain he came here to stole an
eyeball from a wizard bird ward of the
state pre-teen titans go
an uncomfortable amount of r kelly
references believe that you can fly i
believe i can fly i believe i can fight
i believe i can die
and i can fly so i believe make a
live-action gargoyles movie you cowards
can we be done with flossing now please
and through the window
through the wall
[Music]
it's always sparky in philadelphia
okay this is the second dc film with an
annabelle cameo so the conjuring
definitely takes place in this universe
quit teasing us with the cameos already
and then aquaman punched the nun in the
face
[Music]
in a world where warner brothers wishes
jared leto never existed in fact where
all of suicide squad was a lie forget it
ever happened the one part you liked
about the film has been plucked from an
early grave and given her own squad just
don't let her do the tattoos this time
you spelled a tattoo i
was writing a word and i felt it wrong
it's a good time to be pretty
birds of prey and the i'm not reading
that part out loud
meet the birds of prey meet the new
harley quinn eventually a lot of people
in this city want me dead any minute now
the perfect egg sandwich no okay fine
meet harley quinn after a breakup with
jared leto's body double she's out to
prove she's more than just a lady joker
so she's forming her own criminal gang
but not taking it seriously while
cracking jokes in clown makeup and using
goofy weapons to fight a rich guy
dressed in black huh this doesn't really
seem like much of an emancipation to me
more of a sparkly do-over that's not
very scrumptious not even wubbtabulas if
you ask me
explore gotham city like you've never
seen it before
in the daylight ew weird but threatening
to conquer it all is a homicidal trust
fund kid in blackface i mean black mask
but also blackface i got it when i was
embedded with the umgami tribe and congo
concessa ewan mcgregor shines as the
owner of the world's worst club to hang
out at get on
now dance
who blends the lines between sadistic
mob boss bro culture avatar and just gay
enough to hope it slides past the
censors in china so are you guys gay in
the movie
it's very complicated their
relationships is very much
based that there's a want and a need in
there for sure as he hands his way into
another great villain performance
that'll get ripped on for decades
because he's different than the guy in
the comics
really looking forward to hearing about
this and the mandarin until the sun
explodes
gathered to stop him are the titular
birds of prey this is our story uh
almost can we just fast forward to them
teaming up
we're gonna have to work together there
we go there's huntress a realistic
portrayal of how awkward an orphan who
trained to become a murder hobo would
actually be do you know who i am do you
know who i am cassandra cain a kid sorry
kid hey kid keep the kid alive price on
the kid's head you've got the wrong kid
monkey kid get kicked
renee montoya a cop with a special power
to okay she's just a cop and black
canary she sings really loud and uh
kicks good stuff i'm just saying i know
more about katana than these ladies and
i only know four things about katana one
this is katana two she's got my back
three i would advise not getting killed
by her and four her sword traps the
souls of its victims dc does not stand
for developed characters
so suit up for an r-rated ride that's
more bugs bunny than batman so what's
that for me william
but combines a great cast with awesome
fight sequences to make this hot topic
version of beyonce's lemonade that will
thrill and delight your inner teenager
but since it's rated r for no good
reason went unseen by actual teenagers
guess you couldn't tell the story right
without turning that guy's leg into
spaghetti
[Music]
starring
dr quinn offer medicine woman hello my
name is renee montoya you stole my
promotion prepare to die obi-wan jabroni
sonic boom ramona glowers diamonds
digest forever
scar tissue that i'll make you saw the
hottest nightclub in gotham is the black
mass club this place has everything
broken legs sad lounge singers a single
narrow room with no dance floor and a
scared erika it's the thing where your
name is erica and the creepy owner of
the club makes you get on a table and
dance to no music always d.a maybe dr
marvin candle joe exotic 2020 and jared
leto you don't know who that is
sounds like a dick
insane clown's posse
that is why you should never partake in
paying federal income taxes whoa harley
doesn't pay taxes and voted for bernie
now that's some joker stuff
[Music]
after almost a year without a major dc
or marvel release a t delivered a
blockbuster spectacle right when we
wished for it the most
ah i renounced my wish
wonder woman 1984.
did you love patty jenkins earnest take
on wonder woman set against the backdrop
of world war one well skip to the 80s
for no reason and crank up the wacky
hijinks but also crank up the sincere
romance and while you're at it crank up
some big cgi cat fights all while
cranking up the political allegory but
don't forget to crank up the girl power
after you crank through an hour of just
kind of waiting for the plot to get
going
[Music]
oh boy this movie is a mess a hot mess
but still
after a trip to flashback island and a
trip to the same mall from stranger
things catch up with wonder woman she's
gone from wide-eyed optimist to an
insufferable i don't even have a tv
person i don't have a tv ma'am you have
several wow incredible
diana is still not over that guy she
knew 70 years ago for a couple of weeks
tops but when she comes across a magical
wishing
what i said wishing rock not
where would you get that idea oh great
now i can't unsee it she'll wish to hook
up with steve one more time not the real
steve trevor mind you just some random
dude whose body she'll use like a sex
doll while his mind is trapped in the
sunken place how did wonder woman 2 end
up more problematic than a rob schneider
movie please i'm jessica
watch this gal take down max lord a
blond-haired orange-tan con man who
can't be a stand-in for donald trump
because this one loves his son he'll
gain the wish wang's power to make
people's hair blow softly in the wind i
wish i had more help
then go full jafar and set off a climax
so chaotic even the screenwriters don't
know what's
happening what the hell is going on no
one knows any more than that what do you
want me to do i don't know what to do
leading wonder woman to boldly sacrifice
her love to stop other people's dreams
from coming true because we're all
inherently selfish and
evil you cannot have it all
you can only have the truth
wow that is grim are we sure the snyders
weren't more involved
thrill as diana faces a new frenemy and
barbara minerva she's a cute funny
brilliant scientist who
never mind she's a loser who drops her
papers and can't walk in heels boo this
nerd boo her
nerd watch as she copies her whole look
and character arc from that other dc
nerd obsessed with the hero who becomes
a villain mammals a day of reckoning is
coming not that one voila
no
those are disney come on catwoman
[Applause]
afraid we haven't properly housebroken
miss kyle
jake hi kids
that's my name maximilians don't wear it
you look
amazing but no matter how exciting it is
to watch cg gal gadot drown a jellicoal
most of the film is them fighting the
real bad guy of the movie bad guys come
on let me walk you home not going home
how you doing hey there how you doing
hey there beautiful no thank you you
look fantastic hey babe where you going
oh you're pretty hey slow down sexy i've
had my eyes on you for some time
anything else i can get you t
me don't cat call women you guys they'll
literally turn into a cat and fight you
so enjoy a classic be careful what you
wish for story except that no one
actually knew they were making a real
wish so who cares that you likely watch
from the comfort of your own couch while
you scroll down your phone which will
come in handy when you have to google
what are wonder woman's powers again
made something invisible
and in 50 years i've only done it once
haven't subway trains been around since
the 1800s
and eventually how to cancel hbo max
free trial i can't believe we killed the
theater industry for this
starring
amazon wishlist m.c scat cat
durr what's a trash can dude
i was good but i can be better a
washington dc tourism video go there
i found my happy thought and the
original principal powers from sky high
oh man i love sky high
cheetahs never prosper
how was the crown a more exciting series
about a princess diana
from the director of the justice league
trailer comes the film that rose from
the ashes to redeem that burnt orange
tire fire transforming it from a movie
that was two hours long and terrible to
a movie that's four hours long and
mediocre proving once and for all if you
want to look great by comparison
just stand next to joss whedon
the snyder cut for real this time
prepare for a film that wouldn't exist
without a powerful league uniting behind
it joining the internet's most devoted
fans of targeted harassment creatively
bankrupt wb execs a parent company who
would happily piss on the ashes of the
last movie theater to sell more
broadband the writer who sharted out
rise of skywalker and a director who was
already self-indulgent before he
formatted a film for imax knowing it
would be released on a streaming service
i think you just liked how the bars
added more darkness to every scene right
that's free darkness right there baby
black suit up for an entirely different
take on the theatrical release except
for its plot setting main characters and
themes where if you recall a gracie gi
monster covered in spikes wants to
destroy the world who's out to impress
his grey cgi monster boss but this time
follow in excruciating detail as this
grey cgi monster reports his progress to
his gray cgi monster bosses gray cgi
monster executive assistant decide
design
i call to thee i found one of the three
the one that woke and called let me make
a plea to him that i may come home
after i take the combined power of the
two mother boxes i've been able to
[Music]
meanwhile batman is still assembling a
team of heroes to protect the earth
where they will work together to bring
back superman and quickly prove that
there's no point to a justice league
once you've brought back superman
honestly they have nothing to do besides
staying in a neat little line together
[Music]
good job team okay soups take it from
here
with two and a half casablancas worth of
runtime to fill everyone's getting more
character depth like aquaman who doesn't
want to live under the sea but doesn't
want to be where the people are either
because the surface world is full of
horny bjorks
the flash who's ditched the awkward
jokes dostoevsky or awkwardly touching
his wiener next to iris west batman who
has so little to offer the team they
give him and alfred a little airplane to
work on as a treat best minds away in
aerospace couldn't make it fly
wonder woman a goddess haunted by her
own relentless theme music
and cyborg where the change from joss
whedon to zack snyder is most apparent
watch ray fisher shine as the emotional
heart of the story and the heir to
batman's mantle of depression who's lost
his body lost his parents and might be
the only college football star to risk
losing his place on the team for
academic violations that doesn't mean he
can hack into our system to change his
friends grades you know what this dude
plays for gotham you and they just beat
a big ten program like wisconsin not
only does he get a pass for hacking
grades there's a 90 chance bruce wayne
just bought him an escalade
prepare your anus for snyder's trademark
brand of muscular visual filmmaking
packed to the brim with hunks allergic
to their own shirts
[Music]
here
boo boo that woman where every action
scene got immeasurably better thanks to
new additions like amazon horse violence
atlantean bloodbending
the gods of olympus reminding darkseid
who's the
daddy extreme sesame seed close-ups
and heroes who take time to inspire the
next generation before their victims
brains have even finished dripping down
the walls can i be like you someday you
can be anything you want to be but man
at the risk of beating a dead superman
this guy loves his slow
motion
i mean come on the flash's super speed
gets the same treatment as lois lane
putting down a cup of coffee is her
drink going back in time or she just
extra sad about her husband
so gather round for the epic culmination
of a mass movement built around the
sincere belief that it wasn't enough for
zack snyder to do whatever he wanted for
two box office disappointments it's not
enough that grim superhero storytelling
is basically its own genre now
no this film had to exist in its purest
form or rather this film always existed
in its purest form and the 70 million
dollars warner spent on it was for uh
snacks or something but now that it's
finally here snyder's biggest fans can
finally lay down their arms and be
satisfied that their hero's journey got
a proper ending oh come on
so wave as you pass by scenes that were
clearly setting up multiple sequels
teasing fans with the ultimate fantasy
of watching dark side in superman take
the rest of earth to pound town ensuring
that every tweet article or public
statement about warner brothers will get
swarmed with a hashtag restore the
snyder verse something that will never
ever happen until dc's annual firing of
the executives and the next ones make it
happen bullying remains undefeated y'all
wait it's still not over that was a
natural place to stop
welcome entirely new additions like
martian manhunter whose appearance
raises questions like where the [ __ ] has
martian manhunter been and how often
does he hit the town disguised as diane
lane and jared leto's joker finally
sharing a scene with ben affleck's
batman i mean they clearly didn't film
together but you can imagine what it
would be like if they finally shared a
scene who's gonna give you a reach
around
it would suck okay this thing is way too
long and i've been holding in p since
part four can you just roll every time
they say mother box i'll be right back
mother bucks mother boxes mother boxing
mother boxes mother box mother boxes
mother boxes mother boxes mother boxes
mother box mother boxes mother bucks
mother bucks mother box motherboards
other rocks motherbox motherboards
motherbox motherbox motherbox mother
boxes other boxes mother boxes
mother boxes
ah that's better all right time for
starring
daddy warbats i'm rich
wonder woman restorer of ancient art and
antiquities
never mind it's not a phase mom this is
who i am now
every heisting needs an i.t guy
debbie drowner i want to be left alone
this is a bad idea his father's dead
because of us
quips over
mr t
put the water in first so we don't
scrawl the tea
that's probably enough tea and then
leave it to mash
big city elegy
put the spikes back on put the spikes
back on is this movie rushing or
dragging it's dragging maybe this guy
should stop working with robots the boar
is lava i'm made of rocks as you can see
i don't let that intimidate you martha
manhunter
the living joke mira's accent the first
born of beloved queen atlanta you are
the firstborn son of queen atlanta and
your mama's box is so smelly steppenwolf
can track it halfway across the globe
you have been near a mother box the
scent is on you oh
justice league bigger longer and uncut
working on an id sketch
where did they find that sketch artist
the leprechaun guy
[Music]
from the studio who finally buckled and
released the snyder card but are holding
firm with david ayer fans no we are not
going down this road again i don't care
what happened on a submarine wait what
happened on a submarine comes the film
that only exists because james gone made
one too many pedo tweets for disney and
dc swooped in like come on home gunny
boy let the jizz jokes fly it's like
angels are splooting all over us
the suicide squad
what is this movie
some kind of
suicide squad yes but also no get ready
for the same basic premise but a
massively different direction
replacing figurative jokes with actual
jokes endless character introductions
with no character introductions and
changing the title from suicide squad to
the suicide squad see there's a little
duh on the poster so everyone knows it's
a new movie with a bunch of the same
characters oh boy no wonder this bombed
welcome back actors eager to watch the
stank off their last outing as these
characters like viola davis bringing way
too much talent and pedigree to a film
with pete davidson in it okay
joel kinnaman who somehow makes you care
about rick flack to the point where his
death hits the hardest i blame you
katana you're supposed to have his back
and of course margot robbie in her third
appearance as harley quinn
and third wildly different version of
the character going from stripper
scipies to self-actualized badass to a
twee romantic with a head full of
flowers and birds who still manages to
steal the film in a sequence full of
torture dead goons and close-up
footstuff or as tarantino calls it
i'm in a humming hominer
but forget the og squad not that they
ever can there's a whole new side squad
in town featuring idris elba as will
smith said no to the sequel i mean
bloodsport this other sharpshooter on a
mission to save his daughter will have
audiences everywhere wondering if
there's a draft of the script that still
has deadshot's name on it john cena's
peacemaker the kind of guy dwight
schrute imagines himself to be he does
exactly what i do but better i am better
than you have ever been or ever will be
then there's polkadot man a guy cursed
with exploding polka dots on the outside
and the mental state of your typical
incel on the inside ratcatcher 2 who
gets dismissed as a lazy millennial
millennials but i'm pretty sure she just
has mono we're tired colonel we need a
rest
[Music]
a disgusting weasel you wouldn't let
near your children no the other one
some glorified cameos to give james
gunn's buddies a nice payday and the
cutest actually threatening animal
sidekick since the last three cute but
actually threatening animal sidekicks
please please please give us behind the
scenes of stallone's video sessions for
this i need it new dumb friends
follow the smartly crew of outcasts as
they do an adorkable version of the bay
of pigs featuring an extended massacre
of freedom fighters play for laughs
then innocent man had his wiener out
because when the usa has to do a good
old-fashioned south american coup amanda
waller won't hesitate to build a team
with one crucial thing in common
traumatic parent stuff my father's
burdens became too heavy to carry my old
man one day he just
locked me in a crate for 24 hours and it
was full of starving rats his father was
a soldier who trained her son how to
kill from the moment he was born my
mother was a scientist at star lab so
she was obsessed with turning me and my
brothers and sisters into superheroes
she infected me
and we don't really know what's up with
harley quinn's dad but come on it's
nothing good right i think you have a
serious case of daddy issues you all do
even the guardians all do james gunn
hates dads when thanos took my home
world he killed my parents in front of
me every time my sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery just like my own damn
parents who sold me no little baby into
slavery
that's my freaking father and apparently
birds too
so strap in for a chaotic good time with
a little bit of everything hilarious
violence
[Music]
a gen xer's greatest hits mixtape
chapter headings that make you say ooh
disgusting animals that make you say oh
and a finale where rats eat a giant
eyeball that doesn't make you say
come on people see this movie why
couldn't they just call it suicide squad
we're sorry and we promised we did
better this time
starring
well well well if it isn't rickman the
guy who can flag anything
i'm going to become the poker
will smith
why are you showing a blank screen
there's nothing oh i get it
rocky
come on everybody ratatoushi
color be bad
the dick of it astaro is born
saturday narc dies
i'm married
and the air cut who are you going to
show that to god damn people deserve no
i'm gonna need that drive colonel no one
is saying what they did was right that
information gets out it causes an
international incident
suicide squad we're sorry and we promise
we did better this time
it takes everyone way too long to figure
out the anti-starro strategy is just
cover your face feels like that would be
kind of your first reflex if a big
starfish was flying straight at it right
now
[Music]
after superman lives died
batman v superman asylum got locked away
and jj abram's superman flyby crashed
down to earth so jj script
that was
warner brothers just kind of snapped and
said all right you know what [ __ ] it you
want to launch a universe how's this
superman doesn't want to save people
batman is a murderer wonder woman's an
incel and harley quinn takes three
movies to break up with joker who looks
like my co-dealer you all have me now
you're my you're all fired i hate my job
i'm gonna go make spongebob's mouse
repair my plus
the dc extended universe
welcome to the dceu continuity that
compared to marvel's boring but reliable
b student is a chaotic goth nerd who
never lived up to his potential cause
warner's does crap like change the title
after a movie comes out cancel films
they've already announced publicly fight
their own stars swap directors
mid-production and release oopsies cuts
of their films to win back fans in the
sort of behind the scenes drama you get
when the closest thing you have to a
foggy is donald trump's treasury
secretary sheesh no wonder these guys
hated cyborg
meet your typical dceu protagonist
either a naive fish out of water an
angstfield warrior made of sadness or a
quippy jokes are stuck with joss
whedon's bee material my special skills
include viola web design fluent in sign
language they're way too powerful to
worry about
[Applause]
it kind of tickles but when they're
somehow threatened by an irritating
little wimp ooh
i love it
an army of faceless goons
or an angry lump of cgi
they'll harness the power of creatine to
squeeze into a series of costumes so
fetishized they should have their own
only fans silica based quartz sand
fabric abrasion resistant heat resistant
my brother i applaud your choices today
it shouldn't work but hot damn it does
make it through that part of the movie
where they lose their powers
you can't leave him like that
[Music]
and he's some kind of sequel character
or spin-off that will never get followed
up on shouldn't we have a league of our
own oh snap do you know who that is
that's that's the next director's
problem
in a world dominated by disney's mickey
mouse club watch dc's effort to set
themselves apart where marvel wonders
what if the gods were just like us dc
answers they're real and they want
nothing to do with you i used to want to
save the world i don't want to be king
and here's the thing i can't be here
superman was never real
the world instead of adapting the best
storylines of their best comics they'll
let the guys behind blade trinity and
rise of skywalker take their best shot
and instead of quipping all the time
that is america's ass everyone talks
like a 14 year old trying to sound
badass while they skim a wiki page this
is katana she's got my back she can cut
all you in half with one sword stroke
just like moe in the lawn i would advise
not getting killed by her her sword
traps the souls of its victims you know
if it's a choice between this and the
quips then i choose the earbud franchise
[Music]
experience a universe that rests on one
amateur bodybuilder's shoulders zack
snyder the inventor of the
feature-length movie trailer because if
trailers have all the coolest shots then
a four hour long trailer would be
nothing but awesome i mean right bro
watch as he reinvents dc's biggest icons
by taking all the color out literally
and metaphorically and whether or not
you're on board with this super nihilism
cringe while the studio ripped control
of his films away undermines the world
he created and ensures that every fan he
made will reflexively hate anything they
ever do you know i'd expect better from
the people in charge of harry potter and
game of thrones wait no i wouldn't of
course they screwed this up so before
the flash movie resets the timeline or
gets cancelled again or the star gets
canceled again enjoy superhero movies
for the thoughtful enraged troll inside
all of us where the only thing more
dysfunctional than what's happening
behind the camera is every dc hero's
relationship with their parents i have
to go back when i was a kid my dad
traded me for a six pack of beer didn't
think you were ready for them to see the
monster you are not
a monster it's weird that you thought it
meant me mom
it's me
i had no
father my mother sculpted me from clay
and i was brought to life by zeus
well that's neat
starring
mcguffins the codex is krypton's future
the lost trident of atlan the god killer
he's after the change engine his mother
box we gotta cut her heart out a stone
started all this the rock was lost it's
a rock amazing actors given nothing to
do do you really think that
oh wow they just they really just vanish
that's rude dumb voice-over some days my
childhood feels so very far away
and others i can almost see it jules
verne once wrote put two ships in the
open sea without wind or tide
it will come together there were perfect
things
diamond absolutes the truest darkness
is not the absence of light it is the
conviction that the light will never
return bad wigs
[Music]
the one human being keeping these heroes
from becoming complete psychopaths the
director of wonder woman spewed with
warner brothers the director of birds of
prey spew with warner brothers the
director of suicide squad spewed with
warner brothers the director of aquaman
he's pretty chill with warner brothers
actually and the director of three dceu
films spewed with warner brothers hmm
i'm sensing a pattern here you know they
should let warner brothers direct the
movies that way everything can be space
jam too
crisis for infinite dorks
so many of these movies have a scene
where the hero is learning to fly but
can't quite get off the ground
what a perfect metaphor this week's
honest trailer is brought to you by dnd
beyond's battle for beyond subscribe to
ddb's youtube to join the battle
i can't hear you over the sound of my
epic voice
it's your birthday
and we want you to have fun it's your
birthday so let's party everyone